[Musique]
ce qui a commencé à être écrit par les
gilets jaunes a commencé à être écrit
sur les pompes c'est la fraternité qui
m'a poussé c'est drôlement agréable
quand on passe du stade où on se regarde
en chiens de faïence dans sa voiture à
un rond-point ou d'un seul coup on a
l'impression d'être une grande famille
si les gilet jaune arrive un jour à
transformer l'essai et à réunir cette
colère en une force collective
d'opposition peut-être que tous les
citoyens seront écoutés entendus à une
quinzaine de kilomètres de montargis
châteaurenard 2000 habitants
c'est ici que vit jérémy clément auto
entrepreneur dans le bâtiment devenu il
y a deux ans militant gilet jaune puis
l'un des porte parole nationaux du
mouvement bienvenue dans cette france
des campagnes d oublier celles des
commerces fermer des centres bourgs
déserté cette france qui a massivement
endossé le gilet jaune
je pense qu'il ya un taux de 1 taux de
pauvreté à un taux d'oublier qui est
bien supérieur à la moyenne alors c'est
pas la seule région il ya beaucoup
d'autres régions mais ici effectivement
vous avez beaucoup de gens qui galèrent
les gilets jaunes sont allés manifester
pour le droit d'avoir un avenir meilleur
et le résultat c'est que non seulement
on n'est pas écoutés on n'est pas
entendu mais il ya toujours des
décisions qui sont pris envers et contre
qui fin 2018 ces territoires jusque là
muet se sont fait entendre
le mouvement des gilet jaune a vu le
jour ensemble ces citoyens ont créé une
nouvelle façon de protester
réunis sur des rond point devenu théâtre
d'une contestation inédite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux ans plus tard le grand mouvement
s'est essoufflé faisant place à une
multitude d'entités nébuleuse jérémy
clément lui reste militant il se veut
même rassembleur le citoyen d'opposition
politique farouchement engagé ce rêve
dans les coulisses du pouvoir
un engagement qui l'emmène à paris aux
côtés des décideurs aujourd'hui il
rencontre jean lassalle pour nous vous
faites partie des alternatives qui
peuvent avec des citoyens présenter
autre chose et peser suffisamment fort
dans la balance pour qu'on puisse amener
une alternative crédible qui soit autre
que ce qu'on vit aussi bien nous
citoyens que vous en tant que député
mais puisque dès le départ on est
plusieurs à avoir fait le choix de se
dire que soutenir la contestation et
être sur le terrain avec les
contestataires c'était primordial mais
on a fait le choix très rapidement
d'investir le champ politique un
engagement salué par le député candidat
malheureux aux dernières présidentielles
ce n'est que veut devenir un citoyen
chacun d'un tonneau il devient citoyen
trouve à l'autre en comptant la traînée
charger de les citoyens et de proche en
proche en forains found le peuple et je
vais pas que effectivement il faut le
faire avec des hommes et des femmes de
bonne volonté et qui sont dans le même
état d'esprit là notre pays a connu des
périodes semblables et c'est souvent des
inconnus qui se sont levés pour porter à
nouveau un projet qui ensuite est devenu
un cadre décent et y résister on n'a pas
la prétention nous les citoyens de
maîtriser les rouages du système et que
si demain nous avions pouvoir on saurait
quoi en faire et comment définir donc on
a besoin d'experts et on a besoin de
gens d'expérience pour pouvoir justement
quand on aura repris la main à redonner
le pouvoir au peuple
faire en sorte qu'il y ait des gens qui
puissent faire la continuité et cette
fameuse transition parce que ce qu'on
souhaite c'est un changement de régime
ou total
la journée parisienne de jérémy se
poursuit ce matin les rendez-vous sont
nombreux tout se joue pas à paris
maintenant qu'on ne voulait avoir à
faire un conte voulait discuter avec des
gens comme jean lassalle et qui font la
route exprès pour venir vous voir
c'est évidemment à paris ou à
l'assemblée nationale où ici après s'est
passé pas régulier on n'a pas les pieds
dans les institutions toutes les
semaines c'est plutôt même exceptionnel
un agenda quasi ministériel le citoyen
politiser ni candidat ni élus jouent
pourtant la carte de la proximité du
soutien la carte du discours de
compassion de l'espoir aujourd'hui
auprès des restaurateurs à fort boyard
canton pour voir contraints à la
fermeture depuis des mois on peut plus
dans les restaurateurs y a pas que nous
il ya des fournisseurs il ya il ya tout
rungis
on gueule peut pas vivre comme ça nous
on n'est pas des e-commerce
jérémy clément est aujourd'hui le
bienvenu chez ces restaurateurs
désoeuvrés même si l'ancien militant
gilet jaune n'arrive pas en terrain
conquis
nous on fait une manif le lundi 14 à 13
heures aux invalides parce que je peux
me permettre d'en parler à des citoyens
si les gens vont peut-être venir vous
soutenir le lundi nous avec les jets et
jaune c'était très dur à paris pourquoi
parce que on province non mais à paris
on a eu on a eu quand même moins 50
moins 80% type d'affaires c'est qu'elle
ce qui pourrait venir soutenir l'action
de lundi
du lundi 13 après midi aux invalides
seraient ceux qui seront là pour faire
preuve de bienveillance et vous apporter
plus de poids
ça serait pas ce qu'ils n'espèrent plus
rien du système équivalent le démolir on
va y arriver tous ensemble derrière les
raisons merci à nos âges et rémy
des promesses et beaucoup de paroles il
a le verbe facile
une ambition débordante et national mais
son action la plus concrète a pris forme
chez lui à montargis du fameux
rond-point cacahuètes des débuts sont
nés les ronds-points du coeur une
association des des dents trade avec la
solidarité comme maître mot bonjour saut
il nous présente sophie gilet jaune
comme lui elle habite à châlette dans un
appartement dit adapté mais son
quotidien reste parfois difficile semé
d'embûches
regarde ce que je sais c'est pas ça que
tu vois j'ai besoin des petits plats
parce que c'est pas évident et j'ai fait
wow
ce n'est pas grand chose mais pour l
impossible de réaliser les travaux tout
seul je trouve des personnes pour me
faire voilà j'irai mais quelle main sur
l'accueil du coeur sur la main
et oui oui vous c'est comme ça ça va
finir de toute façon va pas demander à
la mdph qui que ce soit on va pas
attendre que tout soit cassée et que ou
qui est un accident pour faire ça donc
premier constat un travail de plus à
faire deux se connaissent sophie a déjà
fait appel au service de l'association
parce qu'il y à son handicap d'abord la
faute à une anesthésie raté en 2016 elle
perdait alors lusage des deux jambes
et puis vient la solitude cette mère
célibataire est veuf depuis peu il nous
reste une fois tout payer 200 euros par
mois au travers des ronds-points du
coeur honnêtement je me sens plus seul
parce que je me sentais vraiment très
seul je le dis j'avais envie d d'idées
suicidaires je voulais mourir je me suis
accroché bon travers mon fils mais
j'étais vraiment mal franchement très
mal et les ronds-points du coeur et les
gilets jaunes ont redonné goût à la vie
je me sens je me suis senti plus celle
du tout et maintenant j'ai envie d'aider
les autres
on paye un système on enrichit un
système et une poignée de gens qui
qui s'intéresse pas à tout ça alors
quand on les écoute évidemment il n'y a
pas de problème c'est tout et tout est
beau tout est joli on va vous trouver
des solutions il n'y a pas de soucis
sauf que la réalité elle est là voilà et
des cas comme sochaux en fauteuil ou pas
on en a on en a plus que ce qu'on est
capable de faire
[Applaudissements]
retour à châteaurenard chez jérémy et en
famille
est-ce que les choix train du nord oui
c'est sûr et certain
axa que j'arrive je sais pas dire non en
tout cas pas avec elle donc pas en
profite
voilà j'en profite tout le temps en
temps il n'ya pas de temps mort le
caprice fonctionne à la neige
[Musique]
l'apprenti militants toujours dans le
contrôle et la maîtrise s'avère chez lui
papa poule
et si la vérité sortait de la bouche de
ses enfants à tous qui idéalement c'est
beaucoup beaucoup d'idéal par exemple
souvent papa désole un peu et souvent je
vais pas dire dans un mois et ça va
péter
papeete mais ça va ça va changer les
choses alors qu'on fait dans un mois ya
toujours rien au delà des sourires cet
engagement récent et immédiat semble
peser sur la tenir
la femme de jérémy porte un regard
critique sur les nouvelles idées
politiques de son mari l'entrepreneur
ouvertement capitaliste en recherche
constante de profits s'est mué en
révolutionnaire
le revirement est brutal pour elle qui
n'a pas souhaité témoigner c'est pas
toujours facile à la maison aussi bien
de leur part avec moi que la part de mon
épouse ça fait aussi partie du jeu
comme je vous le disais on épouse n'a
pas épousé un militant ou un
contestataire ou un râleur et souvent
quand quand elle râle c'est moi qui dit
mais tu préférais que je sois devant la
télé en train de râler ou ou plutôt
essayé de bouger les choses parce qu'on
peut à notre niveau quoi donc on en est
là
pour faire bouger les choses jérémy
clément peut compter sur ses alliés du
début ceux du rond point
philippe y était dès les premiers jours
avec l'envi du changement et l'intimé
conviction qu'une rébellion était en
marche
tout avait démarré à ben arfa son grand
projet tard et vous m'avez je rêvais le
deuxième jour mois avec dimanche le
dimanche et 17h du voir un petit peu
tout le monde philippe est un des
soutiens de la première heure l'un de
ceux qui croient en jérémy qui veulent
le voir grandir émerger lui l'imaginent
même en personnage politique il faut pas
qu'ils prennent trop qui montre vite
palier par palier
mais s'il a une bonne équipe je pense
que ça peut aller loin
on a besoin de confiance et lui il
arrive à instaurer dans la de la
confiance dans le pays
parce que si les gens se rendront compte
qu'il tient il tient ses engagements et
ses paroles ça transcende ça ça redonne
de l'énergie là où on en dépense
énormément
et puis à titre personnel c'est
gratifiant on cherche tous à être
reconnu par quelque chose quelqu'un un
peu importe quoi on cherche on cherche
tous a laissé une empreinte aussi minime
soit elle man anonyme laissé son
empreinte
c'est donc ça devenir homme politique
homme médiatique et toucher du doigt le
pouvoir être à l'origine d'un renouveau
bousculer la société se proclamer
acteurs du changement
faudra compter sur nous si bien sûr les
régionales que le départemental que les
présidentielles que législatives
derrière
[Musique]
dans un pays comme le nôtre c'est pas
normal on est la gauche qui disent que
c'est de la faute des riches et qu'on
ait la droite qui disent que c'est de la
faute des chômeurs c'est les
gouvernements successifs qui nous ont
amenés là je prétends pas représenter un
mouvement déchiré jaune par contre en
tant que citoyen je n'ai pas besoin de
demander la permission pour demain à
aider mon prochain ou bousculer les
lignes ou prendre des décisions qui
pourraient influer positivement sur sur
ce système est sur mon prochain contesté
c'est une bonne chose mais à un moment
donné il faut se rendre légitime
et puis pour assembler il faut faire
preuve de bienveillance cette tolérance
[Musique]